my guest tonight starred on two hugely
popular television series freaks and
geeks and how i met your mother
his films include forgetting sarah
marshall i love you man
and the muppets his beautiful beautiful
new movie our friend is available now
i love this film and we will talk about
that please welcome our friend jason
siegel hey jason
hey man how's it going it's going really
well and i have to say i'm impressed
with your backdrop
thank you it's absolutely gorgeous very
smart
your background says i'm very smart my
background says i have no friends
it actually looks like the basement from
i love you man it does
yes it does actually no this is um it's
a
abandoned theater largo in uh in west
hollywood but
yeah largo is a very special place uh
although it's it has an
odor right now um let's say it might be
left over from me i don't know
you know i walked in and i'm like it's
kind of seagully it's kind of got a
seagull stench uh where
where are you by the way i can see that
you're in a some kind of public library
in a very well-to-do school but where
are you exactly
yes uh well right now right now i'm at
my house
um i live i live like a couple hours
outside of los
angeles to low farm town oh nice do you
like do you like uh
i mean small town living is it is it
boring
is it okay it's boring in a really great
way
uh i really liked i i don't know i'm i
had
grown up in la i had never left and then
i moved to this little town
and pretty instantly like right when i
arrived
i went to the grocery store and a man
sized me up as an outsider
and he was like welcome to town
don't be an [ __ ] wow
okay he said because that would make you
the town
[ __ ] i thought i like this place i
wish someone had told me that when i
came to l.a
i didn't know i just want a penny here
the nice thing about being an [ __ ] i
have found in la is i blend right in
uh no i i really like
i really like knowing my neighbors and
it's a really
nice feeling i like it a lot yeah also
though you do have to
i've always heard that people in small
towns like people like john mellencamp
were always singing the praises of small
towns
but the truth is everyone gossips about
everybody else
so you you have to you've got to make
sure
that you stay on the straight and narrow
and that nobody knows your business
you have to just do nothing you have to
do
absolutely nothing you know i'll tell
you a story that i've never told before
actually
okay i popped up some cabins i live in
an orchard and i popped up some cabins
for if guests come to visit yeah
and uh one of the guys who was popping
up the cabins
made some off-handed joke he was like
what are you uh
you start in a nudist colony and i kind
of laughed it off
i was like yeah and then
like a year later i was at a restaurant
and the waitress was like okay you have
to answer because we're all
taking bets back there is it true you
moved here to open a nudist colony
so that was that was the rumor that
spread around that i was the big nudist
i did something a little like that once
i was in a restaurant and it was after
hours and they were sort of closing the
place down and everybody was like
laughing in a good mood and i said as a
complete joke
um the the waiter was like saying
anything else
and i said cocaine for everyone you know
like whatever
and everybody laughed and the waiter
left and then i sort of got a year later
i went back to the restaurant they're
like well we were here the time you were
demanding cocaine and i'm like
i said and i said i've never done
cocaine in my life i am the squares
i don't do drugs i was kidding and they
were like whatever
whatever yeah i just can't convince them
once it's out there
i tried to express like you know i've
shown my body in several movies
the chances of me like being a nudist
are pretty minimal i'd have a better
body by now
you uh wanna ask you this we're all
going through the same thing
which is total lockdown and you
are in this fairly isolated community
what are you doing to pass the time are
you doing anything now
that you wouldn't normally do uh
well i've been stir crazy like everybody
else uh
and i also made the habit of buying
more stuff than i needed like online you
know like see some control
um but then i noticed which i never
noticed before is so much time that you
get like a sometimes a follow-up email
asking to review the product that you've
bought
and so i've started answering them
with with my actual opinion of the
products yeah well here's the
interesting thing i found out about this
and i think we have one of these and i
want to show it because
i i i really love it we have a birthday
cake flavor of magic spoon and you who
you wrote i just love it so much i ate
it all up oh baby did it taste good
give me more more and more the more
boxes in my pantry the more i'm feeling
happy
exclamation point and then hot patootie
but then you sign it jason siegel the
actor
yeah what i love that you're signing
them
you know you could be anonymous but
you're going the other way
you know i gotta tell you it gives me
such joy like even hearing it read back
i had such a good time every single one
that i've written i've had a really
really good time
yeah you wrote this one for the uh uh
you you bought a uh
bathtub caddy and you wrote i love my
damn bathtub caddy
when i'm washing up after a hard day
having all my goodies just to toe pinch
away as all this big guy has ever wanted
yippee best jason siegel
the actor yeah
i love that i just picture someone
reading that
feeling really good about what they've
made you know i think that's very nice
of you
i'm just curious if i were you i'd start
ordering pizzas
and before you even put in your order
just say hi this is jason siegel the
actor
yeah let's do that most times yeah i
i've been doing that for about 20 years
that's fantastic you're very you're very
comfortable uh with your fame
um i do want to talk to you there's no
way to transition here
uh from laughing to the movie our friend
uh you made this amongst
with some other people you made this
beautiful film
uh i watched it and i watched it alone
i got a link to see the film and i
watched it and it's beautiful and it's
gorgeous
and i'm crying my eyes out at the end
which i don't do because the irish
we don't have emotions and um
or we we suppressed them so much
but i i just walked out of the movie and
that is for me a five-star review
because
i thought it was beautifully done uh and
i thought all the performances were
fantastic
and it's such a powerful story and it's
a true story
which i didn't realize i mean when i was
watching it i didn't know the backstory
that this is
a journalist wrote this story it's the
true story of his wife getting ill
and his best friend helping him through
it
and uh it's absolutely gorgeous thanks
so much
i really appreciate that um
yeah it's so matthew teague lost his
wife to cancer he was a writer and
um this article for edwire and i think
i think that part of it was just
catharsis for him trying to process this
i mean he went through the worst thing
you're going to go through in life
somehow he came out of the other side of
processing this tragedy
as being able to frame it as a story of
friendship um
and that was like incredibly moving to
me
i mean that's the big thing with life
right like how are we going to construct
meaning from these things that happen to
us um
and i just found it uh
kind of really heartbreaking and really
moving i feel really lucky to have been
a part of it
yeah uh dakota johnson is fantastic
in it and um and and casey affleck i
thought was
fantastic and it all feels i mean
as it should it feels very real and it's
hard to explain
but it's harrowing and sad
and then uplifting at the same time and
so
i was the movie's over and i'm crying
and i went and found my wife and i was
just like
hug me please don't ever get sick
but at the same time i
felt better for having seen the movie
and i felt
this great sense of like perspective
does that makes like
it does and i think that part of so i
think it has a couple things that make
it unique our director comes from
documentary
um she's made some narratives but she
also directed blackfish and some other
really great documentaries
and so first off she wasn't interested
in it being a melodrama
she wanted to feel like you know real
depiction of what this process might be
like which like all the great james
brooks movies
you know their life was never one thing
right it's sad and funny and you're
laughing through the hardest parts
um and i thought she did that really
really well
and i think that also she handled the
emotion like a
magic trick where there this humor
and and lightheartedness and friendship
is peppered all the way through
in this way that when when the tragedy
inevitably happens
it it's harder and more emotional
because you've seen
all the good times yes you talk about
the comedy in it
your character is a person who's
struggling to find himself
he can never quite figure out you know
his path in life
and one of the paths he tries to stand
up comedy he's interested in a stand-up
and
i thought well that's really interesting
because there's a part of it where
you're a famously very funny person but
you're very convincing
at playing a character who's naturally
funny but trying stand-up but
not polished and not particularly great
at it
and it was i thought a very accurate
portrayal of someone trying it out
thank you it was the most terrifying
part of doing the movie
honestly really i was not afraid at all
of doing the drama because
i was surrounded by great actors and i
felt like if i
let them take the lead and just try to
be honest on camera i'll be okay
i kind of know how to do that at this
point i've never tried standup
and in the script there's i mean you do
the comedy
you really understand there's some
assumption that someone who does comedy
just
knows how to do all the different stuff
and so in the script it just said
dane does stand up and i i don't
i don't write jokes that way i was
really scared it also had to be mediocre
so i i thought to myself like
what do i do who do i call and i
randomly had
adam sandler's phone number in my phone
because i had congratulated him on
on something he did uh he's made such a
great turn into drama
and i thought oh you know what he's
someone who would understand like i'm
trying to do this drama
maybe he'll be able to help me out so i
texted him like hey i'm so sorry to
bother you this is jason siegel
i'm uh doing a movie where i have to do
stand up do you have any
uh jokes that you might be able to give
me i didn't even know if that was an
appropriate question
right and it was like i i don't
offhand but i have a friend who can send
you some jokes it's my pleasure
i was like oh my god thank god and then
later that night the jokes arrived
and they were so dirty they were like
the dirtiest jokes i've had ever
read in my life and i was embarrassed
reading them
and i hadn't contextualized enough
this was a cancer drama yeah yeah you
didn't say
by the way it's a cancer drama i'm not
doing uh a roast
it's not a roast of sarah silverman
shut my computer at one point
yeah if you um now that thinking about
the movie if your character had gotten
up there and done that
uh stand up in that context it would
have been it would have just ruined the
film
it would have been horrible yeah yeah
well
uh adam sandler needs to pay for what he
did you know
you know what it was the kindest thing
in the world that you thought tried to
send me those jokes
i'll find another contest i don't know
we have a uh we have a clip here from
our friend
i actually don't know which clip this is
do you yes
i believe that this is a clip where um
the family finally is just completely
overwhelmed and they start they're at
each other's throats and things are
really falling apart at home
so i demand that casey affleck's
character matt t
come with me on a hike because that's
how i that's how i process my grief and
so
this is us uh together yeah i know this
scene well let's take a look at this
clip from our friend
you see that also yeah yes i see them
that's nice
what what's funny to you just did your
hair
i did not did your hair no it didn't it
was windy early
first of all they can't even see us
they're not looking at your hair
second of all it's weird to just sit
over here and watch
so we should have to tell them that
we're here so that they know
so they don't you know go skinny dipping
or something
just say someone's over here so they
know we're here
just say something tell them i'm going
to i'm thinking of what to say
just say there are people here it
doesn't matter what you say
there's people here it doesn't matter
what you say
to this day at my age happily married
uh if i if if i out of the corner of my
eye
see attractive women who aren't even
going to see me
i slightly try and adjust my hair yes
it's funny that you say it's funny that
you say at your age because i'm now
reaching the point where people who i
feel are my contemporaries are calling
me
sir and i just hate it
oh i know it's awful it's awful i don't
know what happened but
wait till i think i'm uh i've got some
years on you
and then some and um i think of myself
as this young goofy guy and occasionally
someone offers to help me across the
street
that hasn't happened yet but we know
it's coming um
let me make sure i get this the word out
our friend
is out now in theaters and at home on
demand
and uh it's the best movie i've seen in
a while
i mean in memory i really loved it
and um it's it's got everything it's got
everything and very powerful
and your performance all the
performances were great but i'm really
happy for you
i'm a huge fan of yours and so i did and
i knew nothing about this movie
when i saw it i just knew that you were
in it and that you'd be coming on the
show
and so i went in blank slate and was
just blown away so congratulations
thanks man it just means the world to me
i appreciate that
all right well jason um be well
and uh promise me uh that one day you'll
have me
to that pretentious little library that
you're living in
absolutely we'll play some chess yeah
and then we'll walk around new we'll do
nude we'll walk you through that's okay
all right jason siegel thank you very
much
thank you so much